we are living through time I was
thinking about that this weekend how
time is just such a it won't you can't
stop it I mean you just
it's on it's just uh it's kind of like
the it's the LeBron James of mediums
this [__] is going and sometimes I
realize I'm like hey time time time you
know I'm over here you know hold it up
but timing [__] with you boy
timing [__] with you you little
[__] out here on that lopsided field
get your [__] together being alive you
know making it through the year I'm kind
of amazed how time goes so fast you know
I was brushing on it a little earlier I
mean time time just it's like the
fastest friend you have it and you're
always like come here buddy
and times life
and sometimes I find I even get angry at
time in my brain I'm like time shut it
down guy you're not trying to tighten up
over here and you keep just making me
feel loose because you keep just time is
that guy like when you go on rappelling
and he just keeps throwing rope out
there you know like your boy Larry time
he just roping you out but that's life
man that's life it's that limited time
offer you know life is that limited time
offer where it's just it's so it's the
only show in town that's the thing for
as much as we know it's the only show in
town and so we got to grab this bastard
cuz this is it when we're doing it we're
doing it man we're doing it I'm back on
that Hope bus
all aboard this bus is short but it's
hopeful Sun gang yeah well thanks for
watching that video right there that was
a beautiful little segment I think
but of course I'm partisan to myself but
you can move on to another video right
now you can check on this video or on
this video that's two different options
and you can also subscribe to the
channel check on a new video subscribe
to the channel check subscribe check
gestures curse car